allez cédric 6 m $ dans la vente d'art
qu'elle ait quelques semaines laurent
baffie tu es dans l'oreillette de julien
courbet laurent baffie donc demande
logiquement à julien courbet de se
caresser les partis sauf que vous seriez
vous savez pas que ma fille a déjà
commencé à donner des ordres à julien
ouais donc pensez vraiment que julien
courbet animateur de capital et se
grattent les pois chiches 9 ans toujours
dans le bas des missions est forcément
direct singes ou baba il t'a des plis je
m'entends dire l'installation ménages et
avait donné des conseils pour la suite
de ta carrière
oui alors greg guillotin effectivement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'étais bon compte qui lui parlait déjà
fait mais qu'est ce qui lui prend est en
train de tout [ __ ] en l'air
j'adore ce truc dans touche pas à mon
poste on note très grand animateur télé
comme valérie benaïm ou benjamin
castaldi et puis on est matthieu
delormeau mathieu ce nom mais non non
non il n'y a pas de vannes mathieu je
les plains amateurs c'est un artiste
c'est un génie c'est un artiste vous
allez voir là là franchement ils le pro
depuis quatre saisons
j'ai voulu vous rendre hommage mathieu
parce que vous savez tout faire voici
matthieu delormeau six artistes
c'est un nouveau pas toi
[Musique]
céline your own est troisième c'est
tellement contente c'est mince et les
nerfs pipe hockey quand je t'ai vu pape
le même frau prochain terre de vision
c'est tout de suite su que tu as gagné
tu avais danny manquait elle truc le lit
mineur saluer produc
[Musique]
enfin
qu'on me donne l'envié y vivent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas bon boucher congo na le long
du mois nous faire juste une fois que
c'est possible
shana bien qu'au volant au nom du vivre
leur livre en vie coralie mon ordi
[Applaudissements]
comme ça il attend picard l'amour est
une excuse moi tu avais la chanteuse ira
faire quelqu'un même les chocs arrière
que ces 15 à l'audience avait imité qui
fâchent mais l'exceptionnel satellite
équivaut bruel allez-y c'est quoi cette
chanson c'est bon c'est bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
autre pierre bachelet d'écho que des
morts c'est un vrai souci c'est que
jamais un spectacle et voilà votre
question sur votre carrière
bon ça fait quinze fois d'affilée que
vous êtes élu tarbes à baa1 de celui qui
tacle le plus ses collègues et on verra
dans quelques instants si oui ou non
vous conservez votre titre franchement
j'ai un peu peur pour vous parce que je
crois que c'est la fin d'un règne mais
ça vous venez ça tout à leur nom en
attendant j'ai remarqué que depuis
quelque temps les chroniqueurs se venge
il se revêt lille bouclage de plus en
plus pour évacuer leur frustration ne
pas être rien qui m'a clairement ma
belle et vous allez voir tout ça c'est
le ba-ba clash
[Applaudissements]
nacelle le grand patron bleu grands
patrons du cac la halle et je pense que
lui d'aller garde appelez vous même
[Rires]
tiens très inquiets nous faire une
déclaration d'amour voix off à lui-même
ça va vous sinon de coucher votre mère
j'ai mangé la crise qui a donc voilà ça
y est je suis reparti de 50 à 100
millions d'euros presse et les débats
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé ça très drôle
j'ai roulé sur les nikon ga j'ai roulé
sur la ligne à la baule inquiète pas on
est une famille on peut tout se dire ça
va vous savez que je me plonge pour les
archives
voyez en 2014 avait décidé d'engager
comme chroniqueuse celle qui m'a touché
d'être maman nabil arabi la villa à quoi
la maman d'un petit millan qu'on envoie
sur les embrasse les dommages que j'ai
donc voulu lui rendre hommage aussi on
penche sur ses prestations des pmp parce
qu'il y avait des moments
extraordinaires
elle n'est pas restée longtemps mais il
faut dire qu'elle nous a vraiment offert
de belles séquences ce sont les nabila
de nabila
[Musique]
et chez saint laurent fabius et des
mines et de devoirs et la soif du
poisson
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous disais combien de livres par an de
livres de pages de livres et un truc
pensait on s'en fout vous êtes comme une
fois l'amour parents parents ou par
heure 1 et souvenez-vous ce moment
incroyable nabila nous prouve qu'elle ne
sait même pas ce que veut dire des
moules et un cas cumulés avec un ballon
à bastos
le premier qu'il est mou latentes sur
vous attendez mon top 1 2 3 démouler
[Musique]
là j'ai un truc à vous dire vous avez le
bonjour d'apple
[Musique]
sortir avec un camp qui arrive alors il
ya n'oubliez pas les paroles vous perçu
rende la parole vous allez avoir pour
lapointe enfin un zoom mise à jour et il
sort et surtout parce que je pense c'est
la fin d'un règne qui sera élu le tabac
c'est la fin des rêves chaque fin de
semaine serait que vous fait un point
détaillé sur le manque de prise de
parole des chroniqueurs et ça les
traumatise un petit peu parce qu'ils
rêvent tous d'entrer dans ce classement
alors un qui a le plus parlé qui a le
moins parlé cette semaine vous savez est
ce que jean michel maire était détrôner
de sa place de numéro un c'est n'oubliez
pas de prendre la parole
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans votre
classement 2 n'oubliez pas de bonjour
est ce que vous avez vu un poil de l'udc
dans la le classement qui montre les
meilleures interventions des fournitures
tu peux parler [ __ ] dernière du
classement avec 23 interventions c'est
celle qui a quitté le monde de la
musique pour le monde du bim qui devait
on a des positions celui qui a parlé
trente et une fois cette semaine 31
comme le nombre officiel de ses enfants
c'est benjamin castaldi à la deuxième
place il va se présenter lui-même chez
mr le nom des pmp puil quatre
journalistes peut accessoirement avec
seulement quand d'une intervention ubs
la première place cette seconde oui
voilà mes petites anecdotes que
j'appelle temps raconté hier d'arrêter
ses les chansonniers matin je t'avais
dit dans une école à côté de chez moi et
ses mémoires histoire la liberté il est
aussi leader du classement n'oubliez pas
de prendre part à cette semaine grâce à
toutes ces gentillesses palestine
bretagne dans le dos du policing
naturellement qui se permet même de
prendre la parole en anglais sodomie moi
aussi j'aimerais beaucoup la semaine
prochaine
en bresse et seaux d'eau a devancé notre
coin qui va avoir un bébé qui va donc
faire une baby shower pour fêter
l'arrivée de son enfant
donc forcément si vous avez l'idée
lumineuse de faire une mamie shoah et
voir ce qu'est ce qui est magnifique
c'est que vous n'osez pas la regarder
isabelle quand vous annoncez ça donc qui
fait la tête design morini bosc à une
seule envie vous défoncer la race pour
la première fois voici un zoom isa
les chéris on fera également un nouveau
jeu qui s'appelle mamie shower à la
houlala
[Applaudissements]
alors le moment que vous attendez tous
est arrivé voilà tous les cinq ans on
attend la révélation du nouveau
président république en direct mais nous
tous les jeudis la france attend la
révélation du thar baba celui le plus
tacler ah oui bon ça me dit tout de
suite mais sociale et c'est ce qui est
le plus tacler ses chroniques et ses
collègues toute la semaine qui sera le
16e tard baba cyril hanouna vous avez
emporté trouver 15 fois d'accord 3gs
fois pour ses radios
est ce que vous pensiez vous que
d'habitude suffisante
pour être élue de ses exploits
sincèrement récemment sa servante 7
soleils j'étais imbattable
imbattable mais mais attention il ya un
truc qui joue pas pour moi c'est que
j'étais absente deux jours ça exactement
ce que benjamin a remplacé mardi avec
jacques tôt et est que là c'est pour ça
que j que sur deux jours ça va être dur
c'est peut-être la fin d'un règne
cette semaine c'est fini le 16e tard
baba est attribué à
si vous
l'herbier tenir là on peut dire oui mais
vous êtes jouets si rim il s'est énervé
beaucoup je pense qu'il faut voir du
coup pour marc webb hilal m'a fait une
grosse révélation
je voulais de tout on sait qu'on va
faire une grosse séquence de votre et
tourner les images et en fait ils sont
coupés au dernier étage mais sans leur
dire je savais que c'est ce qu'on fait
avec vous dans l'émotion
même moins fameux reconnaissait
contrairement à ce que les bêtises que
et gilles verdez que c'est pas truqué
puisque ce ils ont ils ont sorti des
deux permet vous avec gilles verdez des
soldes plus connu c'est déjà assez
difficile de cette musique est folle
suivi halliche quoi c'est billy heinich
quoi je suis pas super combi table allez
je vous le dis c'est une super artiste
arrêts superbes s'était répété sa série
culte on sait que dati y avait un micro
trottoir pour savoir ce qu'était la rate
ça attendez attendez vous c'est
indispensable
ben alors à bassam pilotes comme vous
dans l'émission ça
[Applaudissements]
je le mérite
il est choqué lui même regarder vers
l'asie et les neiges a rigolé
[Applaudissements]